all right trivia question sunday
surprise here we go chris since
week 14 of the 2018
season the new york giants are 4-0
against the washington football team
and 2 and 20 against the rest of the
national football league since you are a
giants fan i expect you to know this
name the two non-washington wins for the
giants
all right damn wait uh eli manning beat
the
the dolphins late last year right was
that one of them
that's one okay damn i gotta name both
of them i mean that's that's pretty
messed up you're a giants fan
okay giant's favorite well there haven't
been many wins it's hard to remember
you should remember hold on oh i was
gonna say
the bears would that be
tampa bay buccaneers oh my gosh i knew
it i just
your team a team you played for
all right uh i get to go first sunday
surprise draft
plenty of surprises i i'm gonna start
with matt ryan and uh
you know for him with everything that
was going on for that team
with a new coach with
the covet stuff no work on thursday you
got to practice we saw with the patriots
you got to practice
no practice on thursday so many
different things going on
very easy to just kind of mail it in and
this guy has been laser focused he's
been task oriented he has been
unwavering oh questions last week about
his future
they asked the owner is he going to be
the quarterback yeah anyone was like
it's not up to me it's up to the next
coach hope i
you know if if they if they want him if
he wants to be here
not exactly a ringing endorsement sets
all that aside has 371 yards four
touchdowns no picks
a passer rating of 136.6 against the
vikings defense that you know
when they had xavier rose they were able
to slow down julio jones with no xavier
rose they had no answer for julio jones
that helped but matt ryan his
performance after everything they went
through last week huge surprise
yeah i i hear that i hear you that's one
of the teams i had written down as well
i mean
to go there you know minnesota team that
you know i know has not been great but
made life hard on russell wilson in
moments last week certainly i mean they
didn't just like explode all over the
minnesota vikings defense
and atlanta kind of had their way and of
course the turnovers helped that way too
but yeah good job by matt ryan
uh i think the sunday surprise the
biggest one for me is
you know aaron rodgers and his play that
to me was
the shocker and not that i expect him to
go in there and just necessarily light
the tampa bay buccaneers up i picked the
bucks to win the football game
but i didn't expect it to go like that
where it would be ten nothing you go oh
wow it kind of looks good here and they
kind of look like they got it rolling
and it all turned around because of a
roger's mistake
and then from that point on he just
never looked comfortable he looked like
he second-guessed himself was not
comfortable in the
the pocket i didn't see him just you
know letting the ball
go like we had seen through the first
you know win the first four
games of the year to where he just threw
rifles all over so
uh that to me was probably one of the
shockers of the day not that they lost
but the way they lost
and the fact that rogers you know looked
so average on sunday was uh was shocking
i've noticed you're developing a bit of
a negative streak for your sunday
surprises
you know we have the goats draft
tomorrow uh are are you trying to
preemptively prevent aaron rodgers from
being dubbed a goat
i i well listen i just go by what the
thing that surprises me i don't give a
damn if it's good or bad
so uh you know that shocked me because
you know that's my my buddy and i love
watching him play and
you just don't see him play like that
very often you could have thrown a
bouquet to tom brady as a surprise
you're right i could have i mean yes you
just can't give him any credit
but it just was kind of listen tom did
well but it just wasn't
it wasn't that kind of game either it
wasn't like oh wow that was amazing by
brady and everything like that
shut up i'll pick who i want on my own
surprise draft right i'm just giving you
a hard time deandre swift
lions running back he had his uh best
game of his career and the lions
desperately needed that win over the
jacksonville jaguars 14 carries 116
yards two touchdowns
i mean you know carry on johnson was the
guy then it's adrian peterson
well we got this kid deandre swift we
use the second round draft pick on maybe
he's the guy
and if he's going to play like that and
contribute like that
maybe matt patricia and bob quinn will
find a way to stick around for another
year chris i thought that was a huge
game for them
after a week off if they had lost that
game maybe today we'd be talking about
the lions
having an interim head coach and an
interim gm yeah
i mean maybe you're right um but it was
good good win for them
it was never really in doubt defense
made a few plays and turnovers
really cool to see deandre swift you
know have some big plays in effect on
the game and
we'll see we'll see where the lines are
lions are one of those teams that might
hang around and be annoying and
kind of stay in this conversation a
little longer than maybe we
we expected i i think last night i'm
going to go to i'm going to go to the
49ers defense as being a surprise on
sunday
i mean i'm going to try to do something
positive here but
yeah i think i got to go with that and
first off i think the great advantage
the defense had was shanahan controlled
the ball on the offensive side of the
ball and kept them off the field
but the way they made jared goff and the
rams offense look at times
i know darrell henderson had some good
runs and everything like that
but that pass game for the rams never
looked like it was gonna work all night
long
and really a lot of their drives were
only because of the run game it's a big
question with the rams
they're another one of those teams mike
where i think we can throw into that
like you know group of teams where you
go
if they can't run the ball can they win
the other way
and i'm not sure they can you know they
got away with it against the giants but
the giants stink i mean they're they're
definitely one of the worst teams in
football
but you that that's the big question
about them going forward
if they can't just gash you in the run
game and control you that way
can they drop back and beat you with the
drop back pass game that's the big
question with jared goff and i still
think that's a very much of a
coin flip uh answer at this point
i i uh i'm gonna go and usually i want
to pick someone from a team that won
yeah but i got to give deshaun watson
some credit you know that game very
easily could have gotten away from the
houston texans and
you know it it they started on four
they've gone through the coaching change
and and the deandre hopkins trade you
know be very easy to just say well this
just you know chalk this up to whatever
and we'll figure it out next year when
we hire a coach who's going to coach
deshawn watson to his maximum abilities
he was great yesterday against
a titan's team that had befuddled josh
allen 37
attempts 28 completions 335 passing
yards four touchdowns no picks passer
rating of 138.9
spread the ball around nine catches by
brandon cooks on nine targets
will fuller had six for 123 a 53 yard
touchdown
darren fells had uh a 685
and a touchdown and then randall cobb
three catches 17 yards and a big
touchdown so
i i was very impressed with desean
watson yesterday
in sticking with it against a much
better team
on the road in a season that just feels
like it's kind of you know teetering on
being off the rails for the texans and
yeah they didn't get the win
but i think there's enough good out of
that where
you know you've still got plenty of
games left they can still
try to scratch and claw for the seventh
year in the in the af yeah it's it's
it's not the kind of loss that like it's
devastating but you they're
for a team in their spot where they are
right now they will be able to like look
at some positives
and yeah tennessee the way they played
against the bill's offense just a few
days ago
then to have you know desean watson gash
them up that way that was kind of
shocking
all right i got to go negative here one
more time i just
you know to me the biggest surprise is
sunday maybe this is bigger than all of
them
it's just the pat's slop you know the
slop of the patriots we just don't ever
see that
and i you know they have a great excuse
we know they haven't practiced a whole
lot and they had a lot of issues
definitely
but you know both interceptions by cam
newton
yeah tip passes things like that the
fumble by the tight end we talked about
that
you know some of the runs they let up to
fill up lindsey and company
it just wasn't their kind of day and
really again the snap the botched snap
over his head when they're getting down
in field goal territory
so many opportunities blown by that
patriots football team yesterday just
not used to seeing them play that way
and then not even executing in some of
their biggest moments uh so that was
shocking
curious decisions by bill belichick we
may break down later today on pft pm for
now though let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports